okay we've heard what psychologists
think mr. Popple
how much psychology is there actually to
this well a lot bubble is driven by
expectations or future increases in
prices and that leads to two actual
increases in prices and thereby fueling
the inflating of a bubble so it is
really just the basic economic question
of supply and demand exactly but it's
driven by by cheap money by expectations
not justified by by real factors by
fundamental factors and at a specific
time at a point of time the bubble is
gonna be bursting and then the market is
crashed but also driven by people trying
to make a quick buck exactly exactly
and this fueled by again by by cheap -
by low interest rates and by expectation
of Frisia further price increases let's
take a look at some of the numbers
before and after a property bubble
bursts Spain for example it was going
through a mighty construction boom in
housing prices were already high but
they got ridiculous at one stage then
the bubble burst in 2008 throwing
millions of spaniards out of work it
created an economic crisis of its own
and prior to that the US subprime
mortgage mess it created a global
financial crisis I mean these are things
that are happening over and over again
we heard about the example back 400
years ago in the Netherlands have we
learned nothing
it seems so because it's very difficult
to to learn from a crisis individually
we can collectively learn from crises
and this must lead to a better
regulation of financial markets and is
this where it all comes back to the
psychology of things because we all
expect everything's just gonna get
better we all expect we're going to earn
more prices are gonna keep rising that's
the human nature I would say and it's
hardly and nearly impossible to predict
when a bubble is bursting and so it's
it's a reinventing itself and we can
never say when it will be pristine ok so
we can't do anything about the
predictions but what can we do to
prevent it or at least
for ourselves up economically or
financially well what we have have done
in the recent time is that all of the
crisis was fueled by cheap money in the
beginning of the 2000 years and now we
want to fight the crisis by cheap money
again and this could lead to further
bubbles bursting in five or ten years
and that is the fear or the threat of
the market right now who's pushing for
all that cheap money though it's but
it's politicians isn't it politicians
exactly the central banks who provide
cheap money at low interest rates and
institutional investors are looking are
searching for yields and going into risk
and that could imply that they also
investing in a kind of a bubble because
I don't want to play the blame game here
but you know we're not really to blame
it's the politicians setting the rules
and making up regulations and they they
do try to heavily regulate so many of
these industries don't they mmm
I think they should do because there's
no individual learning from from a
bubble because as you have mentioned
before we have a bubble from time to
time over many many centuries and that
is that we obviously can't learn from
from a bubble so we must regulate these
markets well thank you very much for the
analysis good to have you on made in
Germany you're welcome